i've never made it for her so i really
don't know how it's going to go down hi
i'm keanu tastyproducer and today
myself and my mother are going to see
who has the better steak recipe i think
my dish is still going to beat hers
because this is the original versus the
new thing so today kian and i are making
steak she's making a rib eye and i'm
making a skirt steak so my friend taught
me how to make this dish a while ago and
i'm pretty sure i might have changed it
along the way too and since then i have
been making it for quite a while i used
to make this dish mostly when i'm in a
hurry and i wanted a nice tasty dish for
keanu to eat and she loved it she really
liked flavors of like either either
tomato base or mustard it was a quick
dish for me to make for her in the
evenings because that being in the
kitchen is not my thing the key
ingredients in this dish for me is
really mustard and capers and i'm pretty
sure for keanu she's added a few more
things but i actually love that keanu
has changed this dish to make it her own
i like that she's experimenting on other
things and she's always great in taking
a dish and making it even better so i
like i like that and i like to see her
enjoy it i used to feel like i was a
great cook until she came along and so
i'm usually her sous chef most of the
time in the kitchen so coming up against
her it was
nerve-wracking a little bit but as far
as the dish i like the simplicity of my
version i like that it takes less time
the
meat cooks a lot faster and also i don't
have a lot of ingredients along with it
so you can still taste the meat and not
so much of the sauces today i'm cooking
my rendition of my mother's steak with
mustard sauce this is hands down my
favorite thing i ate growing up like it
was like top of like my request list so
when i make this dish myself
in no way is this like my tuesday night
meal i make it once in the blue moon
on a weekend when i'm just like hanging
out watching loads of movies because i
do have a couple more steps for me it's
like
a meal i take my time with and enjoy
it's very nostalgic i don't have too
many drastic changes
my first change is that i use a
different cut of beef than my mother she
likes skirt steak where
i use rib ribeye
i don't cook this very often and ribey
is my absolute favorite steak so when
i'm cooking steak i'm gonna make my
favorite when it comes to making the pan
sauce i've added a couple more
ingredients i start off with some
shallots it kind of just
rounds out adds a little bit of
sweetness and i fry my capers they get a
little crisp and crunch and they kind of
like cling onto those little meat bits
oh my god it's like
so good and then i kind of deglaze my
pan with some white wine let it reduce
and
and then from there once the mustard's
in add a little a little bit of cream
the cream just helps mellow it out and
it's a bliss my mom more recently found
out that i have my own version of her
recipe i texted her photo once and she
didn't seem that impressed by it like
at all so i've never made it for her
so i really don't know how it's going to
go down maybe she just judged it too
quickly and then like from first bite
she's like oh my child this is so much
better than mine that's what i want
i hope you like this i hope you like
yours
oh my gosh i love it does it look good
yes it looks really good so now it's
time
to taste it so let's switch plates okay
i can't wait as i jump back into the 90s
with mine
oh wow this looks great
i
mean
oh it's actually good
really yeah your sauce i was a little
worried fine when you started putting
the
wine
and the cream i thought you were gonna
change the total flavor but it didn't
this is like i don't want to compare it
to you or so directly like
mom makes this for me and this is what i
make for myself so this is like
good oh my god i love it do you love it
i love it like it's it's so different
like i would never make it for myself
because i rather you make it for me wow
thank you sweetie
[Music]
but i do less sweet in my defense i do
like ribeye more